man
[Music]
there you go [ __ ] it's the Lord's
Day that Jesus won't smoke
[Music]
if
[Music]
you're alive got good night
[Music]
my lovin Pythagorean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] if your lucky night [ __ ]
the church is here to avenge the [ __ ]
death of Bruce Lee in 73 good a 300
[ __ ] years later we're putting the
samples on its although we had enough
we've had enough constructed so
beautiful night to be alive you got a
few minutes to get your [ __ ] together
and then we'll get in this [ __ ] party
started and you and you will be on dates
in go [ __ ] yourself I don't want you
around you little [ __ ] next thing
you know you're crying is happing out
that [ __ ] that's this worst weed in
North America
I don't know why he gives it to me all
the time victims I touched twice I
smoked with some of the more in my Pappy
I just got worse bad breath and without
[Music]
and [ __ ]
[Music]
I don't care well you can link it I
don't care well you could think it I
don't get it hit it oh [ __ ]
here we go cuz you're all I got
tonight you're all I got
tonight
[Music]
Rolle [ __ ] uncle Joey here and full
effect we ain't [ __ ] around tonight
is your lucky night
I'm happy you tuned in we got the jars
that I want you to take a look at the
kind of [ __ ]
this is grown by Martians they drop it
off this morning look at this [ __ ]
monkey do but in the back of this [ __ ]
look at this Oh Lord it it's going to be
your type of [ __ ] that night you filthy
[ __ ] animals you tuned into a good
[ __ ] night lineage ooh and there's
more mumbo-jumbo here understand what it
is do blah blah fizz fizz oh what a
relief it is you don't say we got tons
of weed we got an empty bar with Don
Juan but [ __ ] this little in there if
you're walking on ice you might as well
bet and beside that you woke up it's a
beautiful day to be alive we got buckets
we got [ __ ] chocolates the sky bars
supposedly you see the [ __ ] Lord when
you see things
let's see what's really crack-a-lackin'
that's what we can do here we also
sample new edibles and we let you know
if they even work you're [ __ ] one
sample new restaurants new edibles all
the time you don't think from time to
time you go over there ain't got nothing
you want Oh Lord I'm in milligram
[Music]
we won't even listen to dry cropland a
very long it's a gum sequence on type of
million litres was having out it's a
good thing
subscribe blog how to do flavor to it
it's not overpowering I don't think the
[ __ ] we deter which is advantageous
with some people I'm not making a
no-name no man no mames so not bad 180
milligrams no Google being done will be
happy get many here grown up boy I'm
gonna hear you later
look I told you but don't matter we're
having a good time I'm saying [ __ ] time
we're having a good time let's step it
that should be your attitude all the
[ __ ] time
[ __ ] them I'm having a good time right
here in the tub I got no soap I got no
soap for that number water young man
[ __ ] them
come see comes on it's a Sunday night
August 20th get your [ __ ] together
you're four months away from Santa Claus
[Music]
cut the cars first down run one of the
finest Lisa works there but did I just
the first two Caramba [ __ ] tremendous
panoramas that's where they [ __ ] lost
it they came back from 94 with the armor
to put on the commercial side for me so
I moved on unum saying what's going on
over there
I couldn't Frank shortly right deadly
[Music]
cut that Parisian pastry unit now you're
almost lieutenant Thomas make a lost his
job and he started making chocolate you
I'm saying you never know anyway
remember when [ __ ] doing anything
with THC
you got a hydrate [ __ ] because if
not you have things in your silent you
want to add yesterday eating 15 stars
here drink some water
life ain't a desert here I'm saying
drink some water it's free [ __ ]
eating delicious
we're picking up a new batch of star
once tomorrow or Tuesday scar book 180
yeah well no is he a devil today let's
take this dark chocolate Channel [ __ ]
around if we're going to get a white
chocolate one but then have no white
chocolate got a sample everything this
is this is this is variety as a spice of
life in Italy that's what you always say
nice sure varieties despite the light
but you know me look at this [ __ ] look
how shiny it is it looks like a black
guy with suntan lotion on you this is
funky shine I like it
let me the THC is coming through
[ __ ]
then go try that one mixed couple
overweight
and I don't arrest I don't assess them
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] after he
desirable a couple pockets you two will
be moving in stereo
[Music]
you see up those leaves yeah some people
think about this guy boss they would pay
up so beautiful night to be alive ladies
and gentlemen so whole new [ __ ] weeks
you got the world by the balls
I don't know what the [ __ ] you waiting
for so somebody show up with your house
and bouquet of roses that's never going
to happen
do you guys want their staff a
[ __ ] to the clip monopoly with
James cans appealing to Roman you've
ever seen that many people compliment
you look at loving - it's that type of
night ladies and gentlemen you're
hearing noises you're hearing giving me
people screaming that means the drugs
did that job understand oh [ __ ] it's my
[ __ ] your [ __ ] it's that type of
[ __ ] on a Sunday night ready for
Monday morning I'm just getting you
fired up cuz it's your week
[ __ ] if you're not going to be
on point saying but why even leave the
[ __ ] house when you walk there you
should be hearing dogs by Pink Floyd in
your head you got to be crazy you got to
have a real need you got to sleep on
your toes when you're on the street you
got to be able to pick up the easy meat
with your eyes closed you understand me
don't make me drop that [ __ ] on you get
you [ __ ] let's do dis [ __ ] Lee oh
[ __ ] - oh [ __ ]
if be agostina lonely dilib important
evening check out this wheel I got more
bumpy in addition to see a parson drop
this off of my house that's what you got
a date
[Music]
if you leave that one letter this is
some night mark estate manager double
reckoning
Adamo [ __ ] we don't [ __ ] around here we
don't serve up bad [ __ ] whatever to
pluck it on the other hand let's hope on
this thing it's a good time the door
pocket you want to take a second if we
cool if you're in jujitsu you go back in
your garden you breathe [ __ ] though here
we go boxing that's all you dope you you
follow me so you want to chop your it
that's all for your car not connected
last time I gave another we pulled over
you will need
[Music]
BJP has here on a Sunday [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with that with those
bongos but Jerry Lewis tonight this is
it it's all over we used to do pong it's
a Jerry's kids
now it's bong hits for Jerry easily say
bondage for Jerry and logician you ain't
to clinic til you see Jesus walk yet
look back tilt your head back like the
blood go to the back of your head 3 3 is
stomach open up your lungs warp out and
make sure your bellybutton is you're
fine you this is bong hits 101 you got
to pay yourself for the bong hit most
people think that [ __ ] you know what
you know they want to work they want to
go to [ __ ] with wisdom with with Isis
Syria it was everywhere they want to go
to Syria and cross the street with
American flag on the same thing with a
bong it you got to prepare for it
mentally I'll look up let the blood go
to the backyard
and now you have to what the Russians
did and the Olympics when they walked
out I'm giving you a free [ __ ] course
than what most people pay thousands of
dollars for when they come to uncle
joey's bong it's summer camp I'm giving
it to you guys tonight for free do the
movement with them breathe out when you
do none of your stomach I'm Bionic fine
yes that's the preparation of the fungus
if you don't know now you know let's do
this [ __ ]
our little time on the tool
let's go up do it all the way down the
ones OPP is coming there you go okay Sam
does I'm talking about
[Music]
sign up now uncle joey's summer Banga
camp spaces of limited consumption and
financial aid is always available we
just use you before for some [ __ ] win
you're miserable but look at Sunday
night we're doing it right dog something
the only one that's missing is you
this is it boo boo [ __ ] lounge either
in or go [ __ ] shoot yourself you
miserable [ __ ] you know I love you
[ __ ] we go deep on Sunday night
people into a movie
[Music]
your muggle shoot yourself right here
may not go
look brother good one up junker Dunkirk
is good no wonder my wife will I still
want to see her she's Russian
hand-to-hand combat World War two you
get flashbacks is [ __ ] you know
the hurt no no I got that
please don't say you saw simply you took
us up listen you can put all the tattoos
you want on and get the different
haircut put on your tight jeans they get
a goatee when you're invited to the
party you're throwing money understand
me if you want to turn head low clouds
along a little baby side you fall a
cloud like a [ __ ] devil people will
[ __ ] you over so you're the king of the
party
you're rocking and rolling you like the
guy that knocked over the [ __ ]
Mexican book card you got that type of
popularity understanding
bond hits a run column yeah I could see
those the new summer boy later for next
year we're going to do a winter [ __ ]
bondage spectacular but I haven't
decided if we're going to do it here o
in Michigan to really accept your
[ __ ] lungs old [ __ ] too many amateurs
who wanted to do on it we want to create
a whole professional [ __ ] Reaper
environment
Mikey spermine Michigan would take a
look north insurance
people don't think I know about these
families Michigan when you shoot
somebody that's where you go
the cops will never find you and II for
me Michigan for Traverse City or
Mackinac Island
[Music]
that's preparation in this fabulous
reconnaissance you got a plan ahead
[ __ ] you ready for another
bonding you're going to place that
chocolate before [ __ ] with most of that
if someday night we ain't got time work
the same Vietnam we ain't holding
prisoners you understand me we're going
broke tonight hold on I got to change
the music I'll be right back don't run
away by the way what are your
grandmother's cabinet right now take out
whatever pills you got take a chance
when you mix and match colors do get
some [ __ ] it's your lucky night
[ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] ain't got
time to [ __ ] around no more
there's how old my ashes are that's how
old by [ __ ] outlook there you go the
first puke getting a party to leap you
[Laughter]
right buddy
he's always already so he's all right
and [ __ ] him up when Isis come to me
make him [ __ ] wide go some chili
chicken making Li here was big I hate
dark chocolates with me isn't he hates
dog Charlie
he's [ __ ] you know I never seen a
chubby do H trouble claims I show me one
chubby person who hates chocolate police
I am and you believe this he's like I
took my favorite joke of all time well
Ralphie made told Gabriel Iglesias he
was a vegan and he asked him what he
ain't [ __ ]
acres he hasn't when he eat for [ __ ]
limit acres the [ __ ] so if you back me
chocolate
that's what was that chocolate I counted
two healthy chocolate dark chocolate the
healthy chocolate so I give it to you
[ __ ]
yeah
this is regular chocolate is late you
can look all late when on the wrapper
trying to pick some music relax
[ __ ]
even contain even kanye west got to get
it together
he owns a not money his what's the song
I'm letting you have a little last piece
of you have two last piece of chocolate
es damn and [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ you so I live with
people and one my 50s I'm on my favorite
I'll do my favorite [ __ ] Jam see her
eyes listen to this at 7:00 the morning
born into my sophomore year my mother
would bang on the wall in the morning
turn that [ __ ] down bearish back here
what's up dawg poorly you hit that water
one more piece this is not good let's
copy mr. Bowie in storage
your hands are shaking you believe Nick
he was done it different water got it
one shot okay I can check it this olive
oil you just go for broke though you
think I like the taste but not no I
think the [ __ ] water and I [ __ ]
drink just yeah I got a deal with you
say that I deal with my you know white
15 stars of things there we go
oh [ __ ] little [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with some mob is here coming at
you with the last one out first cut in
the easy
say how [ __ ] created this outlet
[Music]
I got does
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a beautiful Sunday evening we've
enjoyed we've smoked we partake
what is it time for now [ __ ] podcast
as a family what are we going to talk
about I have no [ __ ] idea you'll find
out when you tune it
cut the [ __ ] clear your schedule it's
uncle Joey in your living room
[ __ ]
here we go oh [ __ ]
Grey Poupon again
Oh always what the [ __ ] we're talking
about the same episode of Jeopardy and
this ain't the video thriller you
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
so I'm a few people watching I'm a few
people going to get your heads together
the right way for the week you'll be
ready tomorrow everybody else will be at
work on the races right [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I got nothing but love in my nutsack
racism don't [ __ ] with uncle Joey hey
don't [ __ ] with uncle Joey we got too
much love in my nutsack that's how you
think about your female you got a big
piece of [ __ ] love in your [ __ ]
[ __ ] understand me what are you worried
about get it together
oh [ __ ] is time for Bonnie boo
[Music]
people think that you know they're
running a charity and anybody give a
[ __ ] they ain't giving out [ __ ]
[ __ ] there you go
hanging tip your head back for the blood
no don't breathe being a jet in through
your stomach let that belly button is
fine all right let's go let's get this
[ __ ] mind going to say no [ __ ]
Olympic trial [ __ ] it feels like it
ready the student should look up man
think about what you're going to do look
down let's do it that's a that's the one
I'm talking about that's the one that
killed Dave Lincoln
there you go [ __ ]
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
if you want results uncle Joey's Barnett
summer Cathy will come through for you
hey you got a call from time to time
it's good for the lungs or your doctor
say listen i do wait bong hits a day and
i call he'll say that's tremendous
because you're clapping i'll all the
[ __ ] sucked in your lung anyway we're
here with with 2017 August 20th what the
[ __ ] you don't do with your life you
don't know neither do item 54 I got one
foot in the grave with a banana peel
little youtube.com slash z-plasty and
bam youtube.com classy flash Joey Diaz
that's the place to be [ __ ] I'm
feel about ten minutes let me get my
[ __ ] bearing back and we'll get this
party started
Ontario Thursday Friday Saturday in
process 8 o'clock showw Thursday I
already got three Lindsay Lohan's coming
Alyssa Milano's coming walking Tom Jones
and napkins coming we got Tony Orlando
coming we got a bunch of people coming
down at Sunday night so if I was you go
to improv calm right now and get your
tickets for stereo don't come to me Joey
we're going to sell out I need take it
go [ __ ] yourself I don't you already get
the tickets I mean we all have just 11
stay black to see I get emotional